how many dicks do you think Bobby has
sucked yes of course on purpose
oh he doesn't know he doesn't know
anything about that kind of stuff
everyone knows that I do things I used
to do things like that so don't break it
oh but let me just say the picture a
picture that you painted about your
friendship of this long decade-long
friendship and seeing hookers together I
would assume that you would divulge that
type of information to someone like him
no because I don't help like him people
don't certain people like Sebastian I
can't look at some yeah I'm closer with
Sebastian - I went to his [ __ ]
wedding right but I can't look at
Sebastian Maniscalco because I know how
he is he paints his nails but he's
cleanliness and guy well that's a weird
example I mean we can't have regular
friends you and I can't have right yeah
yeah we just can't but I can't look at
Sebastian and go hey I used to suck I
sucked a couple of dicks in my life a
couple I was younger but what a couple
the first time is like okay you're
experimenting you're a Boy Scout camp I
get it but the second one all with white
boys you know Asian guy and girl they're
the same from behind let me see it as a
kid you've never your butthole you were
never molested what a question you have
at the end of the I'm asking you a
question have you ever been molesters in
my life
you've been molested what yeah what a
thing to ask someone what just lady yeah
but tell you right now I was molested
Bobby yeah you do you'd look at your
Instagram of this podcast it's like a
disturbing tale of debauchery yeah
yeah so I'm just a guest to this
debauchery okay the French so glad
you're here and I want to say I am so
sorry that you were molested I really am
you're a good guy and yours you have a
good soul I'm sorry that some man
touched you in that way you know Pope
really and you also used to be a school
teacher between so when you just walk
out people don't know this but teacher
you were what good he was a sub like
elementary school well you were sort of
a [ __ ] jerk what were you then going
to my sordid past but anyway he started
comedy but people don't know and he quit
because he was I just quit I just didn't
get the open mic seen it it is brutal
and brutal you know at that time
oh my god it was the worst people don't
realize how bad it was I don't even know
how in the 90s late 90s right I didn't
have like the mental constitution to
like yeah I remember being at this club
called mixed nuts oh yeah I remember and
Jay Anthony Brown was the host so I'm
just young comic I got on this show and
like he's on stage killing like that
that kind of black comic killing that's
like you're like oh [ __ ] okay and then
he doesn't know who's next
he looks out at the comics who next you
know yeah yeah and then like literally I
was standing in the front and I felt
like everybody took one step back and it
was just me by myself so I go up I do
like one minute and he's giving me the
light I'm talking about like vigorously
giving me the light so I say on stage
already but I was sucking a bag of dicks
right and then when I get offstage he
proceeds to do like 20 minutes about how
bad I was whoa
I even remember one of the jokes he was
leaving he goes you got the line already
[ __ ] people trying to set their
girlfriend on fire to get you off stage
and you probably in the back crying or
live in the back like wow this is like I
was like 20-something years old I was
like [ __ ] this is how it is and I tell
you the worst is you I think you know
stage for like nine months
you grow up here I know so ever all your
open mics were here in LA
yeah it was all weird experiences having
to go pay member that place way out and
like Aventura was the name of that club
it was like a cabaret it was something
called yeah yeah I forgot what I never
played it
yeah we didn't have a car so I can get
out there oh god you had to pay four
dollars to like perform it was the worst
back the worst [ __ ] show I ever had a
showcase I had was in front of a
all-black crowd and when this one
happened Abby calls me my manners she
goes sweetie I got you an audition for
Montreal but I also invited Will Smith's
production company and all these [ __ ]
people right and it's gonna be at freaky
Monday not freaking Monday what was the
laughs after a while now that the Improv
one Tuesday like freaking something like
that the more bitter Monday Wow and
that's that's [ __ ] brutal
that one's combat comedy right so then
they had this what they had was to eight
year old rappers right before me it was
like kiddin nykänen play what's up -
what the Chris Brown was Chris Ross oh
[ __ ] let's criss cross right so you open
for criss cross what no I so this is
what happens they open so Montreal's
their will submit production company all
black crowd is packed all right and
these two kids go up there and they
destroy the Roscher people are standing
dancing it was insane and then though I
forgot the who who the host was but he
said all right now we got to go back to
stand up and this is a showcase you know
means showcasing form on the worse the
kids don't leave the stage what he tells
the kids all right well you guys are
done and the audience is like now no we
want them right so the kids are up there
like you know on stage kind of like
we're gonna do another song but this
[ __ ] goes nah Bobby Lee he
doesn't even let them leave they're on
the stage when I go up on stage right
so I good up and I start go telling my
joke I don't even know you come so young
I don't even know like hey can you guys
leave or nothing I just kind of go into
my act
I'll lots of different [ __ ] booing me
this and that yeah and I'm literally
crying tears coming down my face and I
don't even finish I start shaking
and I get off and I just remembered this
distinctive moment my friend Jonathan
got sick came to see my get a white dude
mm-hmm and I remember him giving me a
hug
as if to say good luck with the rest of
your life you know man we're gonna go
back to San Diego and probably get a day
job
you know man he was like one of those
Club it literally scarred me for years
yeah this is the same kind of thing that
happened to me at that club and I had a
couple experiences like that I remember
I just got knee surgery okay the way 24
and I was playing basketball on somebody
anyway so I tore my ACL so I just got
just surgery so I had this crutches so
they've got this buddy of my cause
do they need a host at the improv you
should come do it I go I got my crutches
and at the time I was I would you can't
you yeah you have to go I go and I you
know could literally like I don't think
I got one laughs like everyone was just
looking at me oh my god it was like so
brutal and then I remember bringing and
then I thought well maybe he's too crowd
I remember the first comic I brought up
it was earthquake earthquake the first
thing out of his mouth
he starts killing and it's just you know
and then I had to bring up Dana Gould
and it was and I'm just like hold out
forever yeah just my whole career was
like that I just felt like this is my
career I'm on crutches and I'm down and
out and this is the worst experience
ever you know and so this is why like
when I this is why the comedy scene now
these [ __ ] young comics man it's so
[ __ ] spoiled so feeling so entitled
about what they you know and I'm just
like yeah don't pay some dues [ __ ]
you know what I mean I'm kind of my face
this white dude who did a bring a room I
did Brian marnark's bring her along
don't get me started
so this white dude had been up three
times right walks up to me goes hey see
you around the circuit and I want like
this is the Catskills I was doing a show
of vaudeville or something like with the
circuit and no should use that would he
use that word there is no circuit for
you yeah yeah you're not in the circle
on the same play Mike this is like I
remember this this you're not gonna like
this one what I'm about to say now but
I've heard it all believe it or not it
was a female comic I'm not gonna say who
you know and I was like you know I said
I was like hollering at her a little bit
it's just like well I don't date people
that I work with and I was like this is
like I'm president of the company and
you work on the warehouse floor yeah
yeah and I'm just passing every line
saying hey how you doing like we're not
working no the worst thing I did in that
situation it pisses me to [ __ ] off they
were doing a [ __ ] bring a room in the
belly room and this white chick who had
been up her second time she done an ok
side on and didn't see it but she had
gotten a little drunk and she's coming
down the stairs and she's outwardly
saying at the comedy star I just killed
up there yeah I mean I just [ __ ]
killed and I you just hear her coming
down the hallway now I'm in the hallway
right and she walks up to me and she
goes get out of the way to me right I'm
a paid regular right and I go nope and
she goes who the [ __ ] are you
that's what she says I'm a paid regular
here you know she's like well what's
your name I never heard of you oh that's
I'm gonna say that I said this I had a
glass of coke in my hand a glass right I
go just watch me this is how the kind of
power I have
I threw the glass up against the wall it
shattered middle column Brendon comes up
behind me cleans it walks away and I go
there's nothing they can do that's
pretty you know what she said
you're an [ __ ] yeah you know because
that's I hate that [ __ ] I was in I was
doing this show you got a million yeah I
do another one I was the I was out in a
Humboldt whatever it was and because
while those bringer shows adhikam
restore these
people are telling people you know how
Yugi what's your credits these people
are saying oh regular at The Comedy
Store
oh hey I was like yeah I don't I don't
know you who are you
you know don't I said don't say that
[ __ ] yeah cuz you're not a regular at
The Comedy Store because you're
disrespecting all that I had to do do
you know that even [ __ ] know about
what about to say about that you know
you you you you don't ever say that even
[ __ ] wanna know what I have to say
about that [ __ ] right now man I don't
know why it gets me so angry another
thing I hate all right when I hear this
[ __ ] he's been on Showtime Tonight Show
HBO and it's some like God you've never
seen before
yeah you know what I say to him
afterwards what you do the Tonight Show
I will go up to the master why never was
on The Tonight Show
well the [ __ ] before you who
brought you up said that you were on it
I know it's just something I tell them
to say I go know what see cuz I'm gonna
tell her something right now I did The
Tonight Show and I don't even use that
as an intro because I only did it once
that's how sacred that [ __ ] is yeah
don't [ __ ] lie I hate when people
just like bring you up and they just say
whatever to I say hey I know I have a
credit is the best intro gonna business
not you know okay this is your classic
intro for me oh here's this guy ugliest
guy in the business
hila he looks hideous my friend [ __ ]
would I want to be brought up I said hey
[ __ ] you why would I [ __ ] you sir this
is what I say [ __ ] you sir here comes
the goofiest guy nevermind [ __ ] you sir
what you're say you're not saying truth
okay I say [ __ ] like this I talk about
our relationship
right I say I say your credits [ __ ]
mm-hmm
workaholics I say that parrot Jim Carrey
from show Showtime I've said that a
couple of times it just happened it
doesn't matter
I [ __ ] his you know add you still add
a little extra two or two though yeah I
say yeah Bobby's gonna praise you he has
to tell you down twice as hard
Oh
he's got to be like I know I really like
this guy but he [ __ ] [ __ ] on me he'll
always say sweetie I love you it's
always prefaced with I love you and then
he'll trash yeah he'll he'll ask me if
he gives you an orgasm he has to [ __ ] on
your face that's how he is and he does
[Music]